the secret life of pets is the latest
from illumination entertainment these
are the people who brought us Despicable
Me as well as the minions The Lorax and
hop and now we have a movie about pets
and what they do when the owners are
gone
the main character of the movie is max
who has to adjust to having a brother
named Duke a new big dog who kind of is
taking over his territory and due to a
series of mishaps they get lost in the
city of New York and their animal
buddies while their owners are gone have
to go find them and rescue them from the
underbelly of the Animal Society I was
kind of excited for this movie because
I'm a huge animal lover I have two dogs
myself I got my poopy and my middle-aged
older guy and my kitty cat yeah I'm kind
of a sucker for animals I melt
instantaneously at the sight of a cute
animal so I was excited for this movie
because I thought it was going to be a
very fun look at what pets do well we're
away because all of us always have those
little moments or election we align our
house with webcams just to see what
happens when we're gone almost the
entire first three minutes of this movie
is the trailer beat for beat there is
some keen observations about what our
pets are doing at home and how we should
care for them and provide for them but
within about 20 minutes it became really
apparent the movie was just gonna be a
series of slapstick gags it quickly
turns into a Looney Tunes episode and
never stops being one dogs are thrown
into the air looped around clotheslines
thrown off bridges smacked into walls
driving cars just tons of stuff that
really didn't make much sense and well
earlier this year finding Dory did some
very similar things they kept it minimal
the slapstick and finding Dory was there
and it was mostly in good humor when I
walked out as utopia I was like man Judy
Hopps I really liked that character
walking out of this movie I struggled to
remember anyone's names and I actually
had to look them up before filming my
review so that I could get the character
names right that's kind of sad this
movie is a perfectly fine mindless
entertainment cartoon throwaway movie
with cute animals if you're a young kid
or an adult that just wants that this
movie will do just fine for you but if
you're looking for a more slightly
mature
made a film with animals I'd watch
Zootopia my biggest issue with this
movie and the one that kept nagging me
throughout the entire runtime that as
soon as I realized it as soon as I got
that thought in my head I started to
notice it every second is that this film
is almost a beat for beat ripoff of Toy
Story this film opens with the dog max
so excited about being with his owner
his favorite owner oh my gosh he loves
his owners so much life is perfect and
when the owners go away all the animals
come out and do their little secret
society things and they have the little
meetings and they play games and stuff
and everything's perfect for max until a
dog Duke gets introduced and his
territory is just completely ruined and
life suddenly isn't the same anymore and
then they get lost in the city and have
to make their way back home there's even
a climactic chase to get to a truck
this movie is Toy Story it even has a
bit of Toy Story 2 thrown in there when
Max is lost in the city in this film a
group of his friends organize a search
party to find him just like in Toy Story
2 it's actually a little bit sad yes
aesthetically it's it's pets not toys
and there are certain things thrown in
like an underbelly organization of evil
animals led by Kevin Hart as a rabbit
who unfortunately did everything that I
can't stand about Kevin Hart in his
performance I liked him a lot in central
intelligence he really dialed down the
Kevin Hart isms but in this movie he
does basically nothing but scream and
shout over and over again and it got
super annoying unfortunately and I'm a
fan of Kevin Hart's comedy and that's
not really that good because if you're
not a fan of Kevin Hart it's probably
going to grate on you so unfortunately
despite the fact that I think most kids
will probably enjoy this movie and laugh
at it and some adults can find
entertainment in a - I couldn't get past
the fact that illumination entertainment
basically stole a ton of ideas from
Pixar remade Toy Story with pets and it
was really blatant actually I'm going to
give the secret life of pets a c-minus
this should have been like my movie I
mean my wife and I had one dog and then
we adopted another dog that we found in
the garbage and now there
brothers I mean for goodness sakes this
should have been our movie and it just
it really really disappointed me guys
thank you so much as always for watching
this week and I'm also going to have
reviews for Mike and Dave need wedding
dates as well as a review for Lego Star
Wars Force awakens I wasn't planning on
reviewing it but after beating it I
really feel like talking about it guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes